♪ ♪
- EIGHT KILOS.
100%.
PURE GRADE AFGHANI HEROIN.
- [sniffs]
[squeaky sniff]
$100,000 U.S. DOLLARS.
- HOLD UP.
WE SHOULD COUNT IT FIRST.
- MM. MM-HMM.
MM-HMM.
- BE MY GUEST.
- YOU KNOW,
WE GONNA DO A STRAIGHT COUNT
ON THIS RIGHT NOW.
- COUNT IT-COUNT IT?
- YEAH. JUST--
- GOOD IDEA.
- MM-HMM.
- SHOULD PROBABLY
DO IT FAST
SO WE DON'T MAKE
OUR FRIENDS HERE WAIT.
- MM-HMM.
OKAY.
[clears throat]
20, 40, 60, 80,
100, 20, 40, 60,
80, 200--
- HEY, YOU KNOW WHAT? I'M FAST.
LET ME JUST DO IT.
- YOU WANT--OKAY.
- I'LL TAKE CARE OF THAT.
TWO, THREE, FOUR, FIVE,
SIX, SEVEN, EIGHT, NINE...
ONE, TWO, THREE, FOUR, FIVE,
SIX, SEVEN, EIGHT, NINE--
- HEY, WHY--WHY ARE YOU
DOIN' PILES OF NINE?
- IT'S FASTER THAN 10s.
- OH, REALLY?
- I DO MY NINES 10 TIMES, AND
THEN I DO AN EXTRA PILE OF 10.
- FAST. OKAY. YEAH, YEAH.
YOU KNOW, WE--WE SHOULD
PROBABLY BOTH BE COUNTING.
- OH, WELL, LET'S GET TO IT.
THAT'S DOU--DOUBLE TROUBLE.
ALL RIGHT.
AND, ONE, TWO, THREE, FOUR...
- 20, 40, 60, 80, 100...
- FIVE, SIX, SEVEN, EIGHT, NINE.
- 20, 40--
- ONE, TWO, THREE, FOUR--WAIT.
ONE, TWO, THREE, FOUR, FIVE--
- OKAY, I'M SORRY, CAN YOU--
COULD YOU PLE--
- YUP.
- COULD YOU DO SOMETHING
LIKE OVER THERE, PLEASE?
- I'M GONNA TAKE.
- IT'S A LITTLE DISTRACTING.
- OH, YOU KNOW WHAT?
- WHAT'S THAT?
- I GOT IT.
WE COULD TIME ME.
- [gasps] OKAY.
- OKAY, WE TIME ME
COUNTING OUT 1,000.
WE TAKE THAT TIME,
AND THEN WE JUST COUNT MONEY
FOR THAT TIME TIMES 100.
- NO! I G--I GOT IT.
THIS IS IT RIGHT HERE.
I'M GONNA DO A WEB SEARCH
FOR A PICTURE OF $100,000.
OKAY?
- OKAY.
- THEN, YOU KNOW, WE'LL KNOW
WHAT IT'S SUPPOSED TO LOOK LIKE
AND THEN WE CAN
ARRANGE OUR MONEY
TO LOOK EXACTLY LIKE IT.
AND SEE--HERE. HEY. HERE WE GO.
RIGHT HERE, LOOK.
I MEAN, DAMN, THAT LOOKS--
THAT LOOKS JUST LIKE--
A LOT LIKE OUR MONEY.
I THINK WE GOT
$100,000 HERE, FOLKS.
- I THINK WE MADE IT.
- NO, YOU KNOW WHAT?
THAT IS OUR MONEY. I'M SORRY.
I'M SORRY, DO--
EARLIER...
- YEAH.
- WHEN WE WERE COUNTING,
I TOOK A PICTURE OF OUR MONEY
SO I COULD UPLOAD IT
ON YAHOO! ANSWERS.
- OH, DAMN.
- THAT'S RIGHT.
'CAUSE I JUST WANTED TO SEE
IF ANYONE COULD VERIFY
WHAT $100,000 LOOKED LIKE.
- [bleep]!
- OH, YOU GOT IT.
- WHAT WAS I THINKING?
- YOU GOT IT.
- I GOT IT, MAN.
- GO, GO, GO, GO.
- I GOT IT, I GOT IT.
- WHAT THE HELL
ARE YOU DOING, MAN?
- I TH--YOU KNOW,
I WAS GONNA TRY TO RAIN MAN IT.
- OH, THAT'S A PLAN RIGHT THERE.
- THAT'S RIGHT.
OKAY, YEAH, HERE WE GO.
- WE CAN DO THAT.
- OKAY.
YUP, YUP. I GOT THAT.
I GOT THAT.
20, 40, 60...
20, 40, 60, 80...
99,980.
[dramatic music]
♪ ♪
[gunfire]
all: [groaning]
- [panting]